Oh,
also how you were talking about kind of breaking the loop in your behavior.
Like,
oh,
I want to make a change to that one thing,
you know,
to break the Lou and then you start with something small and then it ends up
affecting more thing.
And you mentioned sometimes it's hard because you don't get pats on the back for
those little things,
you know?
Yeah.
So small that it's humiliating that you even have to do the,
yeah.
But in a lot of time to yourself it's like kind of big.
Like I'm like,
Oh,
I'm going to drink eight glasses of water a day now.
You know?
And then it's almost like you're seeking that pat on the back.
Like you want to tell your friend like,
hey,
I drink eight glasses of water now.
And they're just like,
yeah,
so yeah,
I'm right.
And you're like,
why do I even party use kind of like,
why do I even do it then if no one's gonna care,
you know?
Well,
you know,
there,
there's a lesson to be drawn from that too.
In terms of relationships that's really useful psychologically is,
and this is a big mistake that people won't make.
It's like if you want to have a good longterm relationship with someone,
then you watch them constantly and when they do something that you like,
you let them know even if it's a small thing because they're way more likely to
do it again.
You know?
And so sometimes a personal have kind of an inkling about what they might do
that's good or that would be good for your relay,
their relationship with you.
Or that might even just be pleasing to you,
but they won't say anything.
They're like afraid because maybe they won't get attention for it,
but then they do it and you notice it's like,
man,
that's super powerful.
Like you have to be really attentive though.
Cause the good things that people do don't stand out the mistakes they make
stand out and then you say,
well you made a mistake.
It's like,
yeah,
but to,
to watch and to reward someone for doing something small.
Right.
That's,
that's a step in the right direction.
That is a killer strategy.
I found that to be true with my daughter.
She's four and a half now,
but oh yeah,
like that.
Some kids really like some kids are tough and they don't respond to punishment
at all.
That you just can't,
you can't,
you can't intimidate them.
My daughter,
if I just pointed at her,
she would stop.
But my son,
it was like that was just round.
It just laugh.
We just laugh and run away.
So,
but he responded to reward like mad if I watched him and he did something that
was good and I told him that it was like he was just,
yes.
So Dan is good.
Yeah.
It's reward is harder to use,
but it's more effective if you can manage it.
Yeah.
And then that's not like how you say where you're like,
be careful with the reward when you give like too much for you word for these
small things,
you know?
And then they can't really expect.
You can think that that's a problem with the self esteem movement,
you know?
Oh yeah.
Every,
every kid gets a trophy day.
Yeah.
It's,
no,
it's like inflating the currency.
If everything is good,
then nothing is good because their house,
there has to be a distinction.
So yeah,
you want to watch and you want to see when the person's made an effort and you
want to see when they've gone beyond the call of duty and then you want to say,
Hey,
I notice that that was really good.
Yeah.
And,
and it is scarcity really matters in those situations because otherwise it just
turns into noise.
Yeah.
Patronizing noise even,
which is even worse.
It's like,
oh,
you're doing well or you're doing well.
It's like,
leave me alone.
Yeah.
You know,
it's such a lie.
Yeah.
I have a fun time with that actually.
I'll put like if I have to judge all through my kids' lives,
if I had to judge them in their friends and I have three daughters and one son,
usually it was the daughters.
I was being some kind of a judge.
I'm going to judge the dance,
I'm going to judge the little play that they put together.
I'm going to judge the,
uh,
acrobatic routine that they're doing in the backyard that always be judging
these things.
And I would have so much fun because I would say they'd do their little
performance there,
one minute performance,
and they'd come out table how was wasn't and I said,
okay,
first of all,
presentation overall,
I'm giving you a 4.2 I didn't see one smile until you actually got on stage.
That's wrong.
And I would just go through and give them these really shrong critique.
Yeah.
And,
and they loved it.
They loved it.
That's a tension.
Mad they would be happy to and they'd go try it again and try the race.
That 4.3 to a 4.5 they'd be smiles like you could see from a mile away.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I just got done.
I was at a,
at a pool party with a bunch of little kids running around and I ended up
judging the diving competition and all the parents were watching and they were
aghast at what I was doing.
Yeah.
That was at my house by the way.
Oh,
I did it there too.
No,
I do it on a regular basis,
but I did it at your house too,
right?
Yeah.
You've seen it in action.
I give the kids a little nicknames and then,
and then I say,
you know,
you were completely unbalanced when you left the board.
It was almost embarrassing for me to watch it.
Go try it again.
I'm giving you a 2.2 yeah,
go try it again and see if he can bump that up a little bit.
Yeah.
And the kids get all motivated to go up there and I give him a two,
2.5 or do you want to treat,
treated
them like someone who could improve.
Right.
So that's a big deal.
That's,
that's better than,
that's better than a pat on the back.
It's like,
because everyone's flawed and everyone needs to improve.
Also,
when my kids were little,
I taught them how to speak in public.
It took about an hour.
That was it.
So I had them,
they had to read something,
you know,
and so they'd read it and I was across the room and say,
well,
that's not loud enough.
It's like,
I can't hear Ya.
It's like belted out.
And then they get a little louder and said,
no,
I that doesn't want to mean read it way louder than you think you should.
And so they did that.
And I said,
well,
that's about right,
because there's nothing more appalling than listening to some speaker that you
can't hear.
It's like there's just no excuse for that.
And then like,
make it clearer,
put some passion into it,
you know?
And it was,
it was unbelievable how quickly they would pick that up,
you know?
And,
and,
uh,
that also made me sad because,
because it took so little time to get them to do that and then they had it,
you know?
And so,
and that,
that like a critic is your best friend if the critic isn't destructive,
cause it,
what a critic does is say,
look,
you did 10 things and like these five things,
you need some work on those.
They're not good.
And here's some things you could do that would make them better.
And here's two things that you got.
All right,
and here's three things that you did pretty well at.
And so then,
well,
what's the message?
The message is,
hey,
you can handle some actual criticism so you're not some little,
you know,
useless,
wimpy thing that's going to die.
Just because someone isn't telling you that you're already wonderful,
plus you're not already what,
not nearly as wonderful as you could get.
So let's keep that in mind.
And then you know,
you lay out a pathway for improvement and then you treat the kid with some
respect and,
and you also show that being an adult means that you know more than being a kid.
Cause you,
you know,
the kid does something,
you say,
oh that was really good.
It's like,
what are you saying?
Well as an adult,
I don't know any better than you do.
And that's pretty dismal message because the kid is going to be an adult for a
very long time.
And one of the things we do really badly in our culture is model.
Why being an adult is better than being a child because it is better.
You have freedom and you have responsibility and you have autonomy.
And so we're always so concerned about making our kids feel good about
themselves.
It's like they shouldn't be feel good about becoming responsible adults because
they're going to be adults for like 80 years,
and they're going to be kids for like 20 years.
So
the adults,
the goal.